sister sister I'm talking to you please
leave this man your is not you are
married to a man who's a
fically unstable mentally unstable my
sister please email me I'll talk to you
an email I want to talk to a person who
hasit marri to Absolute sister there are
many good Muslim men out there
alhamdulillah yeah I got thank you
sister my dear sister listen to me
carefully I see you like my own sister
this husband of yours is a deluded man
he has look you heard him moral argument
not debunked Quran is plagiarized
debunked anything that he brings sister
he's absolutely brainwashed and he wants
to debate me he thinks the Quran means
submitting to
Allah do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has has helped develop all
lot of us it's extremely beneficial to
do this course definitely recommend this
course to access the free lifechanging
training now 88 it's going upd we need
to call to you guys okay we're going to
go to the next caller uh somebody who
believe that they're saying they're on
the verge of leaving Islam we're going
to see if they're genuine or sincere not
we're going to see in and if they are we
are here to equip and help them inah
let's get the caller of the person who
uh claims that they want to they they're
on the verge of leaving Islam and let's
see how we can help them Salam alum guys
Oham alaikum hey asalam alikum brother
how are you yeah good sister where you
calling from uh I'm calling from New
York uh I spoke to you I think about
your H yeah your husband I think it's
you said about your husband yeah so um
sister what's your situation now so uh
my husband is here actually um he wanted
to speak to you yeah sure let's talk to
him let's talk to him my phone I know
where you pH F Ali you can hear me yeah
I can hear you yes hey what's up man I
didn't want to disturb because you're
having a donation I'm being respectful
and stuff like that that's why it's more
important it's more important than
donations so yeah I was just requesting
that we do you know a sincere debate
basically talking about Islam and you
know not right here but in a more
professional manner because you know I
recalled your conversation with her last
like two weeks ago about hadits and
stuff like that my argument wasn't me
trying to uh basically make her
emotionally uh submissive to a morality
argument I understood that you were
saying that I was trying to bring up
this morality argument so I could kind
of try to make her leave Islam or this
or that it's more in depth than that
right like for example I heard you
talking to the sister just now about the
Aisha situation right now yeah of course
you're right you know um Islam is not
the only place where people have
marriages it's a cultural thing but but
my thing is right you need to reverse
the thinking right everyone have this
whole cognitive dissonance going on when
they're asked about marrying a
six-year-old and consummating marriage
at a nine-year-old the situation is
simple Muhammad is supposed to be a
virtuous person he's supposed to
represent the highest standard of being
a messenger there should be no reason
that he should have married a
six-year-old in the first place because
he could have taken her as a daughter
there is no reason you need to scramble
and try to find validities and American
laws and culture and this and that he is
the sole representation of the highest
messenger he's supposed to be the last
messenger in the line of abrahamic
prophets to you know display the true
word of God so when you look at a man
who is basically submitted by uh the
pleasures of the flesh per se right if
you do a cross analysis for example did
Jesus have 12
wives did he kill people with the sword
but I don't want to go in depth about it
I'm just saying it's a simple example so
when people are trying to defend why he
got married to her at the end of the day
it just shows that he isn't a righteous
person he he is a flawed person that is
submitted to money power control and
slaves and women because I know the
argument you said that for 25 years he
was married to gisha but if you pay
attention to the sir you can see that
they try to portray Muhammad as this
weak illiterate type of person where
kadisha is this you know all power ful
wealthy intelligent woman and then after
she leaves his life when she dies he
basically transforms into this new
person you know when he gets the
revelations from jibriel and then he
goes
about uh on his journey of getting more
wives etc etc you can say as a political
Advantage you
know I've I've understood again it's
like I said before now let's dissect
this one by one may I join as well yeah
sure yeah that would can join as well
yeah um so let's dissect this because
your argument is like I said to your
wife by the way your wife it's we'll
come to that later but she's islamically
should not marry to you because you're
an apostate yeah so let's go to the
argument so the argument is an argument
from morality no problem I'm going to
now is is your wife listening yes I'm
here okay sister listen very carefully
please yeah and you be the judge I
believe you are just yeah I'm not I'm
saying your husband's not listen to the
arguments your husband made yeah okay
he's arguments are from an argument from
morality he's basically saying if your
Prophet was such a righteous man why
would he marry a six-year-old if he was
such a righteous man why would he take
slaves if he was such a righteous man
why would he kill people these are all
moral arguments I'm going to say no
problem let's flip it on you are you a
Christian you're asking me good are you
a Christian yeah are you yes you can say
I straight to Christianity now perfect
no problem you have left Islam because
has bad morality the best man to walk to
Earth the prophet mhammed peace be upon
Him is a bad moral no problem let's go
to Jesus now I need you to be consistent
why because now we're going to
commentate Jesus because your argument
was what your Prophet cannot be a
prophet because he married Aisha at six
and he had slaves and he went to war
okay now then you're going to have to
say bye to God because this is a prophet
prophets we can say we believe we don't
believe in Islam they're sinless they
make mistakes they can make mistakes
yeah we can say that argument sake yeah
you believe prophets can even make sins
in your Bible let's go with your
morality prophets can make sins in your
worldview that's fine but for God
Almighty to make mistakes or morality
it's a no goal then what that means is
the following my uh uh brother if you're
going to reject Prophet Muhammad as a
prophet because of these things he's
done you're going to now say bye to
Christianity and God not a prophet God
why because do you believe Jesus is
god um so
I'm going to answer that question really
quickly and then um I'm going to say
something else really quickly so
basically um you explained to her last
week that uh basically uh Christians say
that the Trinity is believing in three
Gods right so I tried to explain to I'm
just asking if you believe Jesus Is God
I don't want to get into the Trin I'm
just asking do you believe as a
Christian Jesus is
god
well yes in two dis
senses where believe it's good yeah but
it's a little more in-depth answer to
that so but go ahead say say your point
okay that's fine perfect so now you
believe God Almighty is Jesus so Jesus
Is God no problem that's your belief
system that's fine now I'm going to come
and say if Jesus Is God he's also the
god of the Old Testament
correct yes but no at the same
time so sometimes it's good of the Old
Testament and sometimes it's not it you
see I I don't want to go too in depth to
that because the way I'm going to
respond why do you know want to go one
second why do you one second my brother
when it when it comes to the prophet
Muhammad his character you went quite in
depth no problem I respect that you it's
a debate it's a discussion you're you're
you're not insulting me so I would like
to have a civilized dialogue with you
that's fine now I'm saying that you
believe Jesus is the god of the Old
Testament that means God Jesus
stipulated certain regulations and rules
for certain people in the old scripture
to follow which is the Jews that hold
the Old Testament that you carry the
Bible that you have in your hand or in
your house today now in the Book of
Numbers Jesus orders this is God by the
way Jesus says to Moses to go to a
malachite not even am sorry sorry in the
Book of Numbers yeah he tells them to go
to a nation and he says Slaughter
Slaughter what um happening in Gaza now
same thing Slaughter men women everybody
and any girl listen carefully not any
woman any girl that is not been touched
by man a man meaning she's a virgin keep
them for
yourselves now based on your moral
argument you said the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he married Aisha at 6
by the way married not kept her yes
married yeah now the god of the Old
Testament has said the following Jesus
Jesus said to amalaki in first 15 uh
first chapter 1 verse sorry 1 Samuel 15:
2-3 go to amalekites and kill men
children babies donkey in the Book of
Numbers it says go and keep little girls
that are virgins for yourself for what
to clean the windows to what number two
and then there are other descriptions
where it says kill an apostate anyone
that leaves their religion and worse
than other God Stone him kill him now if
your argument is consistent my brother
and if your wife is listening you have
to be just and say the following I
rejected Islam because Muhammad was not
a good role model as a prophet so I said
bye okay I'll say you know what we can
deal with those arguments but let's go
with what you're saying now you have to
say bye-bye to God because God is far
far superior we don't believe we believe
God is perfect so now according to you
are you going to say bye to Jesus for
all the stuff that he said that is
immoral okay um no so two two quick
points so you're not you're not going to
do that just so I connect them right so
you're not going to reject uh you're not
going to leave Jesus no no no cuz I make
a quick on that and
um so before I make a quick comment on
that I just want to jump back to
something real quick so I'm sorry maybe
I broke up a little bit maybe didn't
understand me a little bit I was saying
that um I am going to make the I am
going to comment what you said but I was
trying to explain to in the beginning
that you was trying to say that I was
going after a morality argument now I
understand that all scriptures have many
type of atrocities and many debatable
and controversial things so so therefore
that is not an argument where if we're
going to go say is the numbers by the
way Hebrew Bible not New Testament but
the Hebrew Bible has these atrocities
versus me comparing it to the atrocities
the Arabs committed or maybe Muhammad
committed I know that's not going to be
that's a back and forth argument so
that's why I was trying to explain to
you that my basis is not about leaving
Islam based on the morality I'm trying
to say that there's too many cracks and
that's why I wanted to debate you about
this to prove that Islam was written by
a man had many scribes if you look at
the Hadith you look at the sir it has
too many contradictions where you can
see that the compilation of the book
itself after the death of Muhammad you
can see that this was the creation of
man and that certain type of Revelations
was basically polished reworked and
edited so my point is there is no
problem right if people have belief
systems you can believe in Christians
you can be an atheist agnostic you can
be in a Muslim the issue with Islam is
that because you believe it is the
unchanged unaltered word of God Sharia
law becomes the Divine Law of God so
therefore you should follow everything
word by word but the reality of it is
who said we don't who said we don't no
but the reality no but you you do but
I'm saying the reality of it is this is
nonsensical because it is the word of
man and I can prove it to you through a
debate using history
so that's fine I understand if you can
prove it to me I will leave Islam now if
I don't if I don't if if you don't and I
prove to you that everything you're
uttering is actually ascribed to the
Bible then I'm actually amazed that look
look let me say something brother either
you're you not knowledgeable or either
you're just a person that's really
passionate yeah because you are saying
things that Islam is free from and but
the Bible is actually known for his
corruption I can give you verses and
chapters we'll come to that later let's
stick the topic for now my brother
what's your your name my name is Ian
brother Ian okay Ian listen to me
carefully you came with a moral argument
and I don't know you're telling me no
I'm not coming with a moral argument you
said how could a prophet that is
righteous could do such things as
marrying the Aisha at six um having
slaves going to war etc etc etc I said
let's go with argument sake and use your
argument okay you're saying he cannot be
a prophet because of a b c d okay now
I'm saying God your God Jes Jesus also
done far done not I don't believe this
is wrong because there's context to it
but if we're going to go with the
argument I'm telling you Jesus and by
the way the rabbis say that the Book of
Numbers by the way because the Jewish
rabbis they say that's talking about
three year-old girls by the way three
year old girls half of six is three so
now I'm asking a question how do you
carry on believe in Jesus's God how do
you justify not the prophet how do you
justify morally saying no to Muhammad
peace be upon him but morally saying yes
to Jesus as God who is more Superior God
or a prophet we need to solve this
problem before we move on who is more
Superior Ian God or
Prophet it's obviously God okay good now
if you rejected the prophet Muhammad
based on these things that he done
should you not now say I don't believe
in Jesus anymore because of the things
he stipulated no no because this is the
issue right so tell tell me what you are
associating Yahweh and the God Jesus
Jesus his name is Jesus yeah but you're
associating the Hebrew God right there
two Gods sorry is there two sorry one
are you telling me the god of the Old
Testament is the separate god of the New
Testament so this is where I was trying
to talk about we can get more in depth
about that later so what I'm saying is
if you notice right what is the what is
the Jewish what is the Jewish identity
the Jewish identity is that they are the
basically chosen people right so the
Israelites the chosen people right so
God has basically uh favored them more
than everyone else right but if you'll
notice if you'll notice
the the Israelite God is a vengeful God
right it's a vengeful God so when we
have this split when it comes to the New
Testament the time of Jesus you will
notice that we stray away and we
completely change the narrative and it
goes from the Israelites being the
chosen people to like let's go preach
the word of God to the Gentiles because
everyone is made in the image of God
everyone is equal there is no such thing
as a chosen race anymore so you have
this Divergence coming along so then
when you have the New Testament coming
about you also have this uh change and
reform and what I was trying to explain
to you before is that we'll get more in
depth about that I don't want to go too
much into that but I'm not I'm not
rejecting Muhammad based off a morality
argument I will say
this bro you said it you said it's a
moral argument but I mean I mean if we
yeah well I just want to stick on this
point I'm so sorry I really want to
stick on this point you mentioned moral
arguments slavery prophets marriage to
AA him killing people in war these are
moral arguments okay let me saying to
you what you're saying is I understand
what you're saying you're saying the New
Covenant Jesus said I did not come to
break the law but to fulfill it yes
that's what you're talking about yeah
yeah
but yeah sorry carry on but you like if
we're going to be very specific about it
right have to Jew rejected Jesus right
yes they basically told ponus pilot to
kill him right because he's he claims to
be the king of the Jews right so what
I'm saying is that's why I say this is
going to be a a layered conversation
will be in depth because that's why I
don't want to have it right now but
simply language the language that Jesus
uses is spe specific to the circumstance
the environment and the crowd that he's
delivering it to because he has to be
very right because than so why why why
is it difficult to use that so what what
I'm saying is this I believe that the
reason why Jesus was not a warrior a
leader because at the time he left was a
different Society that's why the prophet
was a leader he fought people who tried
to kill him there's certain things he
done for a reason like Moses yes Moses
is a prophet he's still a prophet you
accept him as a prophet and he did
certain carry out some certain actions
the point I'm saying is this is your
argument the following that Jesus came
with a new law so are you telling me now
because this is where you now stuck
again because are you telling me that
you believe that what God Jesus what
Jesus done and ordered in the Old
Testament is wrong or right just simple
question do you believe when Jesus said
keep the kill men women children and
keep girls who hav't been touched for
yourself do you believe this order from
Jesus is morally correct or
wrong in a morality sense no it's
wrong you're not a Christian anymore you
you just basically said Jesus was wrong
for morally okay bro Ian are you hearing
yourself if a Christian hears this they
would be like if I if a Muslim said that
you know what I'll say you just left the
for of Islam you just you just left
Christianity because you're just saying
that listen to what you're saying Ian
you're now challenging God your God
you're saying God at one Jesus at one
moment of time you was wrong and you
corrected it with the New Testament how
could God be wrong wait wait wait how
could this is what I tried to explain to
you right
yeah I know the the technique is always
used in the Bible as a way of trying to
stray away from the Quran and its flaws
but let me just let me just comment on
that real quick I'm trying to explain to
you right we'll have that conversation
in in in in in depth so it can make
sense I know like I'm generalizing it
right let's have it now let's have it
now let's have it now look I'm here I've
got time I'm saying let's have it now
your wife is listening I'm saying to you
please tell me you just said Jesus as a
God was wrong at one moment of time and
he was immoral you're call God immoral
wait hold on you're listening to me so
yeah what I'm trying to say is that
associating Jesus with the Old Testament
right associating Jesus with the Old
Testament of saying that Jesus commanded
this
right there's layers to it right I
explain to you I don't want to go too
much into it but like I said the
Israelites is the chosen people of God
under Jewish ideology I know that I know
when we come to the time of the New
Testament we say there's no such thing
no more we preach the word of God to
Gentiles right everybody is made in the
image of God so when we talk about the
book The Bible it was written by man it
has many authors right but is inspired
by the message of God is a very big
distinction between but you're not
answering but Ian Ian you're not
answering my question I'm I'm I'm
actually very surprised Ian you're not
answering my question I said to you even
if I go with the argument
there's a Reformation Jesus the god of
test he's changed his mind and he's like
you are still equating immorality to God
if you go to any Christian in I don't
know which church you go to now yeah if
you go to them and say I believe Jesus
the god of the Old Testament the Triune
God was immoral at one time they will
say you need to repent you've just
called God immoral can let me ask you a
question can God
Lie No
but how are you calling God immoral
you're calling God immoral do you
understand what I'm saying this is the
pickle that Christians leave theel in
when they come and criticize the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him we say
there's context to that what is the
context to kill men women and children
and keep little girls which are three
year old for yourself who are virgins so
now you have to which you have done you
have had to call Jesus an immoral God
now when you call him an immoral God
you're not a Christian anymore Ian and I
hope your wife is listening to this
because this is what I'm saying for you
to go like I don't know what kind of a
practiceing Muslim you was before I
don't know how practicing you was I
don't know for that matter yeah for you
to go from Islam to Christianity this is
the pickle you find yourself in because
you're not following forward bro you're
calling God immoral God is Not immoral
I'm a Muslim I believe even if I'm going
to believe it I would say like the god
or the Old Testament if he's like God he
cannot be immoral he has to be moral I'm
a Muslim saying that so it's it's not
making sense man it's not making sense
all if I if I if I can sort of progress
the deadlock as well by understanding
because you say you say you don't want
to get into it but from what I've
understood this you just said that
there's a difference between the
vengeful god of the Israelites and the
vengeful god of the Israelites was
contextual because the Israelites were
specifically assign to that God right
that's what you're
saying in their perspective in their
perspective right but the god of but the
god of the
Israelites was he also the god of the uh
Gentiles the Gentiles at that time he
was he was the the creator of the
universe was he not in their perspective
yes no no I'm saying as in you know like
because the the Israelites they met the
moabites right right they met the
moabites right a different tribe okay
they the moabites believed in a
different in a false god in fact right
didn't it so I'm saying during that
time regardless of what the moabites
believed the god of the Israelite was
what the true God was he
not say one more time brother say the
last one despite of despite the more
despite of the moabites believing in a
false god right at that
time the god of the Israelite was the
creator of the universe was he
not in their persp perspective yes no in
the I'm saying from I'm saying from all
perspectives objectively it's it's free
from it look it doesn't matter what I
think objective reality 2 plus two is
four it doesn't matter who thinks in
their perspective I feel like two plus
two is seven it's irrelevant how I think
or how I feel the objective reality is
God is all knowing he's the all powerful
he has no beginning and he has not end
he is moral all the time he does not lie
I was speaking to a Christian today we
agreed God cannot lie but what I'm
finding the reason you're in this pickle
Ian is because you know now because you
came with a moral argument now that
there's immorality in the Bible the Old
Testament it is still the same God they
worship the Gentiles and image so much
so I was speaking to a Jew I think today
or a couple weeks ago yeah he said that
he believes we as the Gentiles Muslims
we have a chance of going into Paradise
because we didn't associate Partners to
God so what we're seeing is that God is
the same God you're trying to uh com
divide them into two and be like the
Hebrew Israel no they it is the same God
even even if that's true and I agree
with you that there is a covenant that
um changes all the time we don't even
have to go all the way to Jesus it
changes with every Prophet yeah from
Moses and before that the point we're
trying to make here is that you cannot
deny the fact that the god of the
Israelites is the true God yeah he's the
true God yeah regardless of what
confident you have with with him now he
is the true God and if he is the true
God and he's ordered these things to
happen and you know that they happen in
a context then why is that context not
afforded to the prophet Muhammad you see
I know that you you're saying there's
more argum you're saying there's more
argument than just the moral one but you
brought up the moral one and it's
something that we have to discuss and
you have to find an answer to this if
and you know what I think the problem is
my brother the problem is not that
because I don't know how long you've
been Christian so you may not even know
too much
H so I may you may not even be a
Christian for too long the problem is
that you think that your yard stick to
measure reality is Christianity but it
isn't really your yard stick to measure
um reality is a mixture between human
human rights of laws it's
postmodernity it's uh subjectivity and
it's your prison of our times yeah
you're prison of that's what you're
you're using as a yard stick to uh
project
against um relig religion and and people
who came way before us including the god
of the Israelites and this is why you
find it so difficult but I'm saying to
you the yard stick that you're using you
be have to be aware of it we moving at a
very fast pace
tomorrow Society may agree again and say
you know what being gay is wrong yeah
that's that's the problem that you're
facing that something that is so keep
keeps changing so much so that you are
superimposing you know hindsight and
your side Guist onto like a history that
is longer than you and anything that you
know you see and that's what you doing
so it's not consistent and that's why
you can't agree to say I believe in the
god of the Israelites and I believe that
he was moral you can't do that because
you're you're bound by something else
and and and this is sometimes I said you
said something earlier and you said it's
quite simple you said it's very simple
it's not very simple you're talking
about anthropology that it's not within
the span of your lifetime or 50 years
removed this is Thousands years of Mo
it's extremely complex to actually
understand these things and this is a
problem Ali I just wanted to say this a
lot of the people always jump into these
subjects I just have to listen to them I
know they don't know too much about it
that's the problem you jump into subject
thinking they're simple when they're not
they're not they're not they're not and
look Ian look at the end of the day look
I'm just saying this proper yeah because
at the end of the day look um to to us
like you know we we care about I look I
care about you as well you know I don't
I don't as long like you want Paradise
for me I want it for you so to me for
someone to go from Islam to Christianity
out of all religions like the most
illogical religion like I'll be honest
with you so many people come to Islam
and the main concern from Christianity
that was an ex- Christian yeah why
because the Theology of Christianity
doesn't make sense and you was talking
about the Quran being made by men bro if
you no disrespect the if you knew just
10% of how the Quran is preserved as a
Christian for you to come it's like a
little boy going to Mike Tyson in his
prime time and saying I'll knock you out
and he's like look you have no idea the
point is this the Quran is the only
preserved scripture and I can easily
prove that to you now I can disprove you
the Bible in matter of minutes so what
I'm saying is sticking the topic we'll
come to that later you have now just
said words of blasphemy in your religion
you've just called God immoral so to me
to do that that shows I don't think
you're at a place at the moment look I
don't know why you left Islam I don't
know what's the reason I don't know the
reason yeah but if this is the
reason look you're not you you've gone
from if you're argu is that you've gone
to somewhere which is far worse not that
I'm saying Islam is because there's
context to those things I can answer all
of those Prophet killing people prophets
marriage to Aisha I've spoken to
non-muslims who have listened to it and
said that makes sense it makes sense
yeah so what I'm saying is the following
if I can speak to your if it's okay your
wife if it's possible sister are you
there yes I'm here yeah look like like I
said before look I I at the end of the
day look I'm just the reason I just
wanted to have this discussion by the
way I emailed you I just emailed you now
yeah is this is a reason sister yeah
this is why it's so important that's why
in Islam as a Muslim woman you're not
allowed to marry you know why because
not I'm seeing in I don't believe Ian is
a bad person yeah but it's just that
influence that could be from wherever it
can have an impact on you so Ian look at
the end of the day he's on his journey
he's looking I'm sure he's searching for
the right path ETA I understand his
worries but this can come at the cost of
you losing your hair after both of you
for that matter any of us for that
matter so what I'm saying is and I would
say take time out look into objective
just say look I'm going to look into
them just without any uh bias any
animosity nothing just I did this 11
years ago I came to Islam Islam would
have been the last religion I choose my
dad hates it my dad till this day hates
Islam I chose it because it is the truth
and it has evidence I can prove the
Quran is from God right now um you know
when we associate Jesus's name with the
Old Testament I'm I'm talking about the
New Testament right now right yeah Jesus
taught in Parables right he taught him
Parables he tried to give what he taught
in Parables for a specific reason right
because it was to stray away from the
backward thinking of the Israelites
right it was to stray away from that
there's hidden messages there's
allegories there's Illusions and the
thing is what you don't understand is
what I'm trying to get at is you need to
prove to me when we debate I'm going to
prove to you that Islam is a basically a
fabrication of okay no problem
Christianity responsible said about
Jesus though please your history shows
that this book had insertion eraser
marks tape coverings your preservation
is on Leaf Stones parchment Stones Palm
stocks the most idiotic thing is that Z
is the number one scribe from Muhammad
he didn't even remember the Quran by his
heart he had to go search for it he had
to go search for it but it's the
preserved word of God tell it to me tell
it to me prove it to me I thought so now
what I'm going to do is the following
I'm going to fully
destroy just with one argument look look
you didn't give me one verse cuz you
can't even if they tried that's why you
couldn't you know why I'm happy your
wife is listening to this and she can
see what kind of a man you are yeah okay
she can see what kind of man she was
married to now you said the you said the
the Quran copy from the Bible
yeah yeah if I said what you said that
the Quran coming from the
Bible what do you mean by coming from
the Bible you said the Quran copied the
Bible it is plagiarism Fabrications yeah
of course perfect perfect watch this now
sister are you listening yes I'm here
okay the moral argument went in the bin
Quran preservation argument went in the
bin now check this out I want to see how
you're going to get out of this because
the last two it was a failure maybe this
okay now if the Quran is copied from the
Bible it would copy like a lot of stuff
from it correct like it will copy some
passages here and there okay um Ian what
is the ruler's name at the time of
Joseph in the Bible brother I'm not
going do you can do itan come on you can
do it Ian what is the
ruler Don't Run Away Don't Run Away
Don't Run Away Don't Run Away you said
the Quan from the Bible listen I what is
the ruler called in the Bible when it
refers to the Jo Jose time the Bible was
written by man you written by man
inspired by inspired inspired by
inspired by God thank you so if God is
inspiring them and if they are making a
mistake is it them making a mistake or
God you're in trouble you're in
trouble what does the Quran mean what
does the Quran mean Ali you're running
what does the Quran mean look I'm just
showing your wife what kind of ignorant
man you are and an insincere man look
Ian what does the Quran mean the Quran
what does it
mean dis subit to
God okay one second one second please
pleas please no don't I'm so sorry
please forgive me I love you I love you
okay you turning red my brother no no no
no you know why let me tell you you know
why yeah let me tell you yeah brother he
goes I go to him what Quran he goes to
submit to Allah I know he it's wrong
it's wrong listen listen I you don't
even qualify for me to even talk to you
here let's on a debate now one second
one second no you can't ask me no
question question zero questions yeah
the only question that can ask is from
your wife not you yeah okay because I
believe she's more sincere and has more
knowledge than you could ever have yeah
okay so now so now look the Quran is
copying from the Bible but for some odd
reason it doesn't call it Pharaoh it
says King and then the historians they
say well hold on a second there were no
pharaohs at the time of Joseph according
to your
by to the sister and I hope this man
he's not violence towards you after you
you
Pro this guy you believe in a suicidal
person who sister I'm talking to you
please leave this man your is B it's not
valid you are married to a man who's a
fenic unstable mentally unstable my
sister please email me I'll talk to an
email I want to talk to a person
lit marri to Absolute sister there are
many Muslim men out there
alhamdulillah is B this guy is an
absolute joke he's an absolute clown
insincere person yeah so I waiting for
your email sister hopefully he doesn't
try to um get in the way I've sent you
an email sister sister I've sent you an
email may God help you and I would say
leave this man as soon as possible
that's what I'm going to say this guy is
he's not sincere he is absolutely
brainwashed may Allah guide Him Sister
divorce him you get divorce him there is
no marriage there is is no married
sister leave this person and please I've
sent you an email and I think you just
replied back yeah I got email you sister
my dear sister listen to me carefully I
see you like my own sister this husband
of yours is a deluded man he has look
you heard him moral argument no debunk
Quran is plagiarized debunk anything
that he brings sister he's absolutely
brainwashed and he wants to debate me he
thinks the Quran means submitting to
Allah can he recite Surah FAA can you
Rec fa who me no no him
yeah
um my dear sister if you I don't know
what to say sister if you stay with this
man after this day all I'm gonna say is
and let me tell you something your Nika
is Battle Sister there is no nah with
this man just so you know so I'm gonna
end on that there's nothing else why
would you debate me on your live channel
so I can embarrass you from a you're a
man you're Absolut embarass you from
your audience you scared man you're
here man